[Music]
alright guys we are all experiencing
sheltering in and not going anywhere
being confined to our homes and
depending on the size of our homes it
could be very small and you know
claustrophobic whatnot right now this
article my house is like two rooms of
Bart's yeah thanks name is Mike same my
house is literally the same square
footage of when I lived in an apartment
yeah it's 1,400 square feet Oh No
twelve twelve or fourteen yeah that's a
big apartment my apartment house
probably was 750 okay do you live in
downtown yeah downtown is just yeah so
they interviewed someone with some very
credible credentials I guess that's a
credible credential yeah something like
that
and they interviewed them about what we
should be doing while we're sheltering
in and our individual confined spaces so
he's not a natural healer he's a real
credible quitter he is an explorer of
sorts he is an astronaut and astronauts
this guy in particular yeah his name is
Scott Kelly he spent a whole year in
space yeah and he was recently
interviewed and he offered a little bit
of advice as to what he did for a whole
year being quarantined in a space
shuttle or whatever by himself
he was by himself was he also um on Joe
Rogan's podcast I do not need you want
to buy himself all the time because
people come in the International Space
Station so people that the country is
fly up there I'm sure for most of the
time he is by himself
yeah limited amount of people maybe as
many people as you have in your home
maybe your family or whatever he flew up
there with like Russians Wow he was
telling his experienced Russians and
Americans fly together yeah we don't we
don't shoot any rockets up there the
Russians have it and that's how SpaceX
started cuz the SpaceX was like you
talking about such a badass he's like
okay Russia how much does it cost to buy
a rocket and the brush is like this much
and she's like that's too expensive I'm
gonna make my own rocket and that's how
he started spare make it
yeah that's exactly how he did it well
yeah he please say you know the Russian
rocket is super scary cuz it's like
Russian made in all janky and [ __ ] and
he's cramming there with two other
people with a tip top of this rocket
like just hoping you could make it
isn't that all rockets though a much
every single space innovate and when
they take off it's not like Star Trek
was like when they're all like common
like no and if you think about it you
think about the Americans shuttles right
when you think of Apollo and [ __ ] and
that's like this big ship where they're
their [ __ ] sitting in this one's the tip
of a rocket where three guys are crammed
right next to each other hoping you
don't explode it's completely different
damn but you wouldn't even know if you
exploded I feel like I was like instant
death
yeah for sure you won't even know any of
it why do you get like superhot they
feel like the heat of everything good
going it's crazy that's crazy but yeah
so this guy um he's an astronaut and he
his number one tip was to maintain a
schedule is that are we all doing that
here yeah yeah what kind of schedules
are you guys doing I'm here it's a
little bit easier cuz he forces you to
have a schedule if you want to get [ __ ]
done so like he wakes up 6:30 7:00 so I
like to still do podcast or if we have
to get any like important like business
stuff or emails out of the way then we
have to wake up at like 4:00 or 5:00 do
that and then after after he gets up
then I work out and after I work out and
I work and then we have like scheduled
family time so it's like everyday it's
kind of rinse and repeat and so like my
schedule technically hasn't really
changed much from pre quarantine to pre
quarantine except that I'm at home way
more so the location changed and there's
way more family time because there is
less work to go around sounds good so
it's a yes I love it
actually uh I've been loving cuz you
would have got to here after like your
busy business stuff was like more in
place like if like all the things that
we're planning to do for JK barbel right
and then you would have probably got to
here but you got to you got to do this
earlier cuz a quarantine yeah
that's time yeah so I've been loved in
quarantine actually me too
same yeah cuz like I am enjoying
quarantine as well like I am valk a pot
you got a schedule so wake up at 5:00
p.m. you think no I wake up at 9:50 for
my 10 o'clock meeting Oh sick yeah you
get ready and brush your teeth and do
all the normal get ready for work stuff
or now you just just come out of nice
crowd baby likes oh god oh damn they're
very casual I love the studio that I
work at it's awesome because it has
elements of like my like my previous
works out here at JK hmm okay I mean
it's still entertainment yeah and I feel
fortunate that like I'm able to work
from home as well too but yeah everyday
10:00 to 7:00 except for weekends
weekends I just do whatever I probably
slept a ton right when I came back cuz I
was jetlag and then I was like oh [ __ ] I
didn't know I needed sleep so much and
then I started getting into this weird
jetlag where I sleep at like 9 or 10 and
I wake up at 4 and I love that because I
was naturally sleeping and waking up
with no alarm and I was hella productive
the only thing I didn't like was I got
tired as hell at like 6 so that's why I
was forced to just unwind and just eat
and chill at 6 take a bath chill and
then like fighting myself to not go to
sleep until like 9 I love that kind of
jet lag to like the kind where it just
makes you get up early and it makes you
sleep early I love that but it's kind of
like in quarantine it doesn't really
matter and you realize that weed oak and
you get a head start you're oh wait
before anyone else you get your [ __ ]
done then you have your meetings and
then after that you can run to him now
it's like it doesn't matter like I could
besides just Amir that's true go to
sleep at 4 or 5 a.m.
sleep through the rest of the day wake
up at 6 p.m. and then just do my own
thing that's true but I like how a
feeling song and running yeah productive
still that's true yeah they think he was
saying here and in the article and I
would have to agree with it having
structuring your day allows you to have
purpose for you know for it for the long
run you know he's like maybe you want
every once in a while is going to sleep
at like 5:00 a.m. is okay but
like in the long run if your schedule is
like some nights I sleep at 4:00 a.m.
some days I'm waking about 3 p.m. you
know and then eventually if that lasts
like a whole 2 months that's how you get
depressed yeah exactly like you need
purpose in life exactly so it's the
structure kind of like holds you down to
something a little more like you know
you can kind of just grasp throughout
each day and then having a consistent
sleeping schedule is also really
important because getting enough sleep
and having consistent bedtime
I think it's Esther allows for it
regulates your cognition mood and
interpersonal relations so if you're you
know if you're in a relationship you're
courting with someone else you know if
you're getting through some arguments
maybe try to be on a regular schedule
and maybe uh you know you might be in a
better position to you know be with
someone in the close come to I've been
in such a good mood
I've even braking regularly I've been
sleeping like eight hours and in all the
days that I'm like I feel like I want to
go back to sleep I do I can't go back to
sleep I'll just lay in bed but then I
slowly get up and I'm like alright i
chilled enough now it's time to run and
now it's time to move but if I don't do
the activity physical activity I think
that's what makes me feel depressed
tonight in one day of that or like I
laid in bed for a couple hours I was
just on the phone and I got up I made
some food and I sat around and I never
got my heart going and then that's when
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm feeling bad and
my mind's going in circles
and I can't do this yes I you
subconsciously need to feel like you're
being productive even though you're not
actually thinking I need to be
productive like yeah when you when I
waste the day away it's like [ __ ] like
you bad I feel yeah you feel guilty for
not having done anything your usual my
human human piece of garbage being
useless yeah I don't know you guys but
the way I look at like my day now I see
the Sun as such a precious commodity so
I'm like alright what can I do before
the Sun Goes Down and I'm like what
system goes down I'm like aw [ __ ] I ran
out of some time
like I'm just like okay I need to get up
earlier because the Sun set this time
what can I finish during the time in
which the sun's still up you know
yes but also cuz I spent all my time the
garage and muscle fun going on I'm like
where's everything there's no light hi
yeah there's no amount of work like that
substitutes Sun cuz it's like from
everything yeah yeah yeah well the
lights I just ordered on Amazon just
came in yesterday so as soon as nothing
[ __ ] bright are they like like film
lights like HM - no I got these long LED
tubes you don't have a garage light
right now it just has that one sensor
garage dark I'm like I can't see
anything
yeah but yeah I just I also feel better
with the Sun that's why I also like
working out during the day and night
that's why I hated to go into this one
LA Fitness I was underground and you
couldn't see the window one and um a
hamburger Pasadena yeah yeah there's a
few underground I hate it because I feel
like when I can see the Sun I'm like
energized and like ready to go yeah yeah
I I see everyone complaining about like
because maybe for some other people it
sucks they don't know how to deal with
it they're constantly being out they
need people but they act like it's like
in prison like solitary confinement I
just I just feel like people who are
complaining like that they don't want to
deal with their own issues you don't
wanna deal with their own issues the
thing with that is uh because in
solitary confinement it makes you go
crazy and they say it's not good for the
prisoners hey I live alone I've been
alone for 20-something days I just want
to see how that affects people after
this but even the people in solitary
confinement like the one that survived
they have a schedule - oh yeah they'll
try to deal I'll do a ten push-ups
forever I don't know what an hour that's
passed in my mind I give them the ball
yeah they give them like do something
you know what's it look like it's just
like cement what is it cement cement I
thought that ball thing was just in
movies no because I've seen videos
everyone like wow like saying if this is
like common practice or should we
continue this and probably walking
leaders grab the ball start bouncing it
I sleep ditto I'm just like relaxing
especially yeah cuz I think a lot of
things I realized was one I'm sleep
deprived I thought that I was
enough and I realized that I never felt
fully recovered and this is how it feels
like to be fully recovered to is I
wasn't moving enough because I feel
loose every day like my body doesn't
feel tight anywhere even though I'm
working out multiple times a day like it
was the one hour of just working out and
in the rest of the day sitting that was
[ __ ] me up I'm able to stretch
through all this other things yeah and
then three is like really being busy
doing the things that I want to do not
the things that I have to do that
there's a difference between the two
yeah because what do you have to do as a
chore what you want to do is I being in
in my back here picking lemons for two
hours that was fun [ __ ] should make
it tricky yeah like a BB gun at our
shoot them off now just picture all the
lemons being destroyed being shot do you
ever like a sword or anything that'd be
fine chairs like samurai kind of manga
he has it here I have other swords oh
yeah here's a picture of uh Scott Kelly
the astronaut that's crazy
it's like the Bahamas I know imagine
waking up and seeing that as your view
man wait aboard of it the earth is
beautiful you know that's for TV Lou
okay that's true you don't want to be at
Netflix you see what multiple sunrises
and sunsets a day on that thing it's
crazy do you think he's introvert or
extrovert
I wonder if most astronauts kind of like
it would probably help that they were
more introvert at home I want to see him
live I'm Chyna I think he said he was
pretty introverted he said he was bad at
school and everything at that back then
too and all of a sudden one day and
caught like college times he's like I'm
gonna get my [ __ ] together
he just got smart all right you just
like got textbooks he started talking
[ __ ] together but it wasn't like high
school and stuff he was not good at
school even you can be an astronaut
any quarantine time is a great time for
you get to know yourself I know myself
both my hands which is probably why
you're enjoying
which is why you're enjoying your time
alone I think I
cuz I have a lot of like mutual like
France or contact like people from
college like they would say that like oh
I wish we weren't under quarantine
because now I don't have other things to
distract me and I'm for my sadness yeah
so just like them I was like well like I
realized the outside world was my
sadness
cuz I'm happy with what's going on
that's healthy
[Music]